[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul aka
the guy whose zombie jokes cost him an
arm and a leg
in this video we're breaking down
kingdom ashen of the north
kingdom is a series that i've absolutely
loved and season two of the netflix show
ended with our group of heroes
encountering a brand new character
as they tried to get to the bottom of
who was the brains behind the zombie
outbreak
whilst we were all expecting a third
season the creators of kingdom decided
to do a break neck twist
and release a prequel movie that
discusses the origins of ashin
this is the mysterious figure from last
time and i felt like calling this a
beginning explained as it details the
roots of the zombie plant
and why we should be hyped for season
three from here on out full spoil is
ahead so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out
and watching past this point is a grave
mistake
if it's no skin off your back i'd
massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel as that's a no-brainer without
the way thank you for clicking this
now let's get into kingdom action of the
north okay so the special episode sets
up ashin
a peasant villager who lived with her
mother and father the latter of whom
was egyptian these were a group of
people who belonged to one of china's
final dynasties
before the mongol conquest in the
century briar the king had given the
churchins a piece of land
and he and his family settled in josian
and built a home there
because the land did not truly belong to
them the native georgian people viewed
them as a low-born peasant class
and thus they had forced them to remain
in the village doing menial jobs
the land itself was also highly sought
after and in the film we also meet the
bajawi
an army of which had gathered their
people at the basin of the pajero river
due to rising tensions the josians
recruited several churches
including ashin's father who would be
used to spy on the activities of the
pajaoi
he hoped that this would improve his
people's standing and their lives
but unfortunately things don't happen
that way now whilst all this is going on
some pajama men enter a forest in order
to illegally collect a herb called
ginseng
which will help with their harvest
they're murdered and their deaths are
attributed to a wild zombified tiger
though it's revealed that this was
actually a cover-up and that it was
carried out by the choklan
ashin's father was then framed and set
up to make it look like he betrayed his
own people
which leads to the pajari turning their
hate towards the churchians instead of
the joshians
the pajari leader adigan seeks revenge
and they launch an attack and murder
everyone in the village except for
ashen's father
he's taken hostage and i at this point i
am kind of glossing over the amazing
tiger fight
well we'll rather tiger chase as there's
a lot of territorial things to discuss
but yeah the action scenes don't slack
now the tiger is actually how they
discovered it hadn't ate anyone
as it was already dead and thus they
learned the truth now whilst all this
was going on ashin was looking into the
resurrection plan as a way to heal her
dying mother
and thus this sets up a lot of pieces
that come to be prevalent in the series
early on the plot and tribes are a bit
hard to follow but at the heart of this
is ashen's driving quest for revenge and
to murder all those who destroyed her
village
and people it becomes clear that she
lives with this and will live with it
forever
as when she returns to her village she
imagines her family there
but what we see is simply a group of the
undead waiting to feast
bringing them back is how she knows that
the resurrection plan works
and why she's so confident later on that
she can build an army of the undead
as a child ashen unwittingly seeks help
from the very man who betrayed her
father
and made it so that her home was
destroyed you will likely know of the
cho clan from the first two seasons of
the show
and i love how this family are pretty
much the bad guys throughout the entire
series
it ties this all together and i think
actually offers a way out for the good
guys in the main show
they of course were against the cho clan
2 and thus moving forward there
is potential that we see them let
bygones be bygones because of the defeat
of the chose
i'll talk about that later on though and
as a teen ashen started to train so that
one day she could get revenge
and she began doing jobs for the
commanders this involved spying on the
pajaoi
and this is where she discovered her
father after having his legs and arms
amputated
he was labeled as a traitor and forced
to live a life of constant pain
as their prisoner ashin's father wanted
death and she ended up obliging this and
burning the entire location to the
ground
now because of this ashen wants answers
and this is where the need for revenge
is further fueled
after discovering specific scrolls that
detail how her father was framed in
order to avert a war
she decides to kill all who had a hand
in destroying her family and village
she returns to her base and that knight
is visited by a soldier who abused her
she kills him and turns him into the
undead before unleashing him on the camp
from the rooftop she picks off any
survivors and you have to hand it to her
she's one of the deadliest if not the
deadliest combatant in the entire show
so far
using the last soldier as bait she draws
the zombies together and wipes them all
out with fire
leaving the entire army destroyed ashin
takes what initially appears to be a
sack back to her village
but it's revealed to be the commander
and they feast on him whilst he's alive
for years they had existed because she
brought them livestock
but now they have something better human
food which he thinks they'll enjoy even
more
she promises to provide them with only
delicious meals from now on
and from here we watch as a sort of
montage plays out
which involves selling the resurrection
plant this would of course lead to the
events that we saw play out in the first
and second season
and it starts to sell the seeds of where
everything went wrong
now at this point ashen has kind of went
off the deep end and we learned that she
wishes to kill
every living thing in joseon and
georgian and then join the undead after
her mission is complete
the special ends with ashin coming face
to face with ardagan
and his group of soldiers she notches an
arrow up
and now they outnumber her she fires it
at him no doubt killing him in the
process
she is of course an expert with a bow
and arrow and the rest of the group
would have to ride towards her
so she might have even killed them
before they managed to reach her
so though her revenge is complete she
still wishes to murder people and the
second season of course ended with her
coming face to face with the central
cast
when we left then they were traveling to
find out where the reincarnation plant
was coming from
and they discovered a number of the
undead in chains we now know that these
are part of her village
and i really can't wait to see how
season three starts off
i think with the way things are left
that the two sides will be opposites to
one another
but i do hope that the animosity is
pushed to the side in some way
however due to ashin's psychosis and the
way that she views her villages is still
being alive
she could be propped up as a major
villain that will be the big bad of the
third season
ashing could easily let the chains loose
and thus swarm everyone
and this would allow her to escape one
of the big questions hanging over the
finale
was how was the resurrection plan still
spreading and it's clear that she was
the cause of this
so i'm not sure if a quest for revenge
will stop anytime
soon now i really really like ashen so i
would love for her to get some
redemption
but i also feel that it may be
impossible at this point due to what's
happened
kingdom as a whole was very much about
the class struggle and ashen very much
represents the uprising of the poor
to me the show was very much playing on
the phrase eat the rich which was coined
by john jack rousseau
in full he said when the poor have
nothing left to eat they'll eat the rich
and yeah that that's basically what
kingdom is for me i kind of think that
ashen might even come out on top
and potentially she could kill every
character and like she says
go off and join her village that would
be an incredible ending to me and very
dark
and though i do want to see the good
guys win i also want to see ashen win
as well interestingly kingdom 2 had a
seven year time jump in which we saw a
new prince rising up that was immune to
the infection
and thus it is possible that ashen sees
him as a way to rescue her people
there isn't really a way to bring them
back at this point but maybe she becomes
fixated on this and even tries to kidnap
the boy
so she can study him another possibility
is that she actually missed with the
arrow
as we did see i'd again dodging them
like it was the matrix
perhaps she is still out to kill them
and that's why she's had this grudge for
so long
and he could be propped up as the next
big bad that they have to join forces to
fight
i know i'm kind of caping a lot for
ashen at the moment and hoping that
she's good
but who knows there is still hope there
however the realistic side of me
says that she's gonna be the bad guy
kind of hoping she is because she's an
awesome character
and i can't wait to go back and re-watch
everything from the start
now as for my thoughts on the special i
have to say i really enjoyed it and so
far the show has had three great
releases
i probably would rank this slightly
below the two seasons but it's still an
incredible entry
and i'm glad we get to see some things
from ashen's side so we can understand
her motives
it's gonna add such an interesting
dynamic to the show and now we have two
sides that we can root for
instead of just being focused on the one
to me that's
really good storytelling and also
character development
i think the show yeah it just excels at
everything it tries
it's got so many things going on with it
and adding this string to their bow has
made the series one of the best zombie
properties out there
tonally it's excellent too and as a
period piece it just manages to capture
things so well
it leads to kingdom action of the north
being an incredible special laced with
political metaphors
amazing acting and also action scenes
hopefully the third season of kingdom
isn't too far away as this has got me
hungry for more
and it gets a 9 out of 10. obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on kingdom
and where you think things will be going
in the future comment below and let me
know
and just to let you know we're running a
competition right now and giving away
three mcu box sets on the 30th of july
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
so message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if that's you if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our ending explain
breakdown of fear street
which will be linked on screen right now
that's the last netflix special i did
and i had a lot of fun with it
so definitely go watch it right after
this if not well thank you for sitting
through the video
i've been paul and i hope you enjoy the
rest of the week take care
peace